hey what's up guys I got a very special
video for you today we're going to be
harnessing the power of 3D software to
transform ourselves from fleshy meat
bags into cute and custom little puppet
buddies all puppet with a VR controller
now this is an effect that my stream
producer SL Discord moderator sotoon
came up with and he's going to be here
any second to guide us through the
process where was I but he is not here
yet
[Music]
so
this is my tutorial
now this is an intermediate to Advanced
tutorial which means I won't be showing
every single button press or click so
feel free to take the ideas shown in
this video and apply them to programs
like an real engine Maya or Cinema 4D
with that being said you guys probably
can't wait to turn your mortal bodies
into puppets so let's jump into
it we will start with the design in 2D
and once we have figured it out we'll
make it in 3D this way we know that the
design Works without having to invest as
much time let's start with the big
shapes first and then go into the
details since I'm turning Clint into a
puppet let's take a look at the defining
features starting with his head don't
only think about your head shape in real
life also take into a counter
personality Clint has a squarish face
shape and he's a strong climber in his
human form so he gives me Square Vibes
so his head will be this shape let's
also give him some glasses and the Torso
with arms we will give him some red eyes
as he's a vamper now ha but you can
choose black eyes for a more classic
Muppet look or Go Fancy and choose to
give it some more realistic eyes with
irises I personally think that simple
eyes give a nicer effect but feel free
to prove me wrong the mouth is pretty
important in a puppet because it's the
thing that moves the most so I recommend
having a large
mouth let's also have in mind that the
design has to work in motion when
animated we want to have as much
movement in a puppet as possible to make
it feel alive but we can only use one
hand to control it puppeteers usually
tackle this problem by by adding
elements that kind of move by themselves
like feathers in Animal from the Muppets
or the ears in rol of the dog this is
called secondary Motion in Clint's case
I'll make the arms body and glasses have
secondary motion we will see the
technical side of how to add secondary
motion to these parts in the riging
section but it's something to keep in
mind when designing the puppet as
well now that we have the design let's
model the puppet I'm going to start with
the head having the 2D design as a
reference plane here in blender I'll
create a cube and apply a subdivision
modifier then at Loop Cuts where needed
to shape it making sure to get it as
close as possible to the drawing from
the front and side views I sculpted some
shapes to make the hair once I'm happy
with the Silhouettes I'll merge them and
keep sculpting until I have a single
shape that I'm happy with I'll follow
the same process I used for the head to
create the nose ears eyes and glasses
sometimes it's useful to model only one
half of an object and then add a mirror
modifier with clipping on this can not
only save time but also make it more
comfortable to select and move things
around and finally for the body just
create the main shape and then duplicate
and modify it to make the clothes to
your liking a lot of puppet makers skip
making the legs as they're rarely seen
so feel free to do that too if you want
and now we have a completed Clint puppet
model which means it's time to make our
materials I'm going to keep it simple
I'm just using a principal bsdf Shader
with some fabric textures for the
clothes I'm also using a principal bsdf
Shader for the foam Parts with some
noise going to the color and normal to
give it some variety and of course don't
forget to add some hair particles to
make it all fuzzy and fluffy and nice
just enable Advanced and add a little
bit of brown and and a little bit of
dump bada bing you should have an
awesome looking puppet right now let me
see oh yeah cool now it's time to rig
this thing so that we can Puppeteer it
this section is going to be the most
technical but don't be scared it's not
as H as it seems and it's very
interesting all right let's think about
this together when you RI character the
root bone this is the bone where the
other Bones come from is located in the
center of gravity around the hip area
however we actually want the root bone
to be here at the head so the movement
will trickle down to the rest of the
body from there we can extrude the spine
and the arms from it I'll also add a
couple of bones for the glasses because
I want them to wiggle secondary motion
remember now par the geometry to the rig
with automatic weights and weight paint
has needed to correct some parts it's
very helpful to have auton normalized
toggle on that way when you add weights
to one bone blender will automatically
take that weight away from the other
bones ensuring that the total weights
add up to 100% very handy to have the
tight clothes match the body weights you
can create a data transfer modifier
select the body check vertex data and
vertex
groups then apply it now the weights
should match the bodies very closely to
rig the mouth I decided to use a shape
key for the mouth opening instead of a
bone for the jaw as it lets me control
the shape of the mouth a bit better for
physics I will be using an called Wiggle
2 after installing it just select some
bones in post mode and in the animation
panel enable it for the scene then
select bone tail now when we Press Play
in our timeline the Bones have physics
feel free to play with the settings on
each bone to get different
results by this point we have a great
looking puppet with a rig and ragal
physics so let's go ahead and make a
cool shot where the puppet is stalking
and moving first we need some dialogue
to Puppeteer to so let's record the
sound want to turn yourself into a 3D
puppet this week well join us for the
weekly Challen on my Discord server
wonderful now it's time to get some
movement my favorite part now we can
animate the head by hand and get a
pretty cool puppet animation only having
to key frame the head and mouth but if
you have a VR headset that can connect
to your computer I have something better
for you we're going to motion capture
hand and puer in real time I will be
using a program called mocha Fusion VR
you can find it on Steam for free or
Linked In the description below once
inside Fusion VR we can open the menu
and click record the puppeteering itself
couldn't be easier just move your hand
as if you were petering a real puppet
and use your index finger to push on the
trigger to open and close the mouth the
harder you press the more it will close
I recommend having the audio recorded
playing on Loop and just do a couple
versions like that once we're done press
the A or B button again and the
recording will stop let's export the
scene by clicking the export tab it's a
bit hard to find but here it is then
give it a name and click on scene
lastly let's click on the open folder
button and hop back into the computer
here open the folder with the name of
your VR scene and open the blender file
called scene loader once inside click
this play icon to run the script and the
skeleton should appear with your
animation make sure to scale the key
frames so that it's real time in your
frame rate in my case 30 FPS and copy
paste your rig into your working scene
now that we have the rig and the motion
capture skeleton we will connect our
puppet rig to the capture one I like to
use a child of constraint in the
headbone instead of directly parenting
it just because it's a little easier to
enable and disable it we'll parent the
headbone to the right hand bone in the
VR R and Bam when we hit play the puppet
is moving to connect the mouth to our
trigger press I'll add a driver to the
open and closing shape key in the driver
editor I'll select the first bone in the
index and look at its local rotation on
the x-axis this will change based on how
we pushed the trigger in the motion
capture process so if we set up the
points in the graph correctly we can
have it talk as we Puppeteer
it awesome at this point we have a
puppet that moves in a really fun and
believable way congrats the hard part is
over now we can relax and make it look
pretty with lights and rendering and
compositing for lighting I will be using
an HRI and adding some lights where I
see fit to add a bit of spice to it
since we have all of this fuzz on the
puppet it really helps to have a
backlight so that the fuzz catches the
light and we get a nice Rim lighting
enable motion blur turn on depth of
field make it transparent and let's H
render want to turn yourself into a 3D
puppet this week well join us for the
weekly challenge on my Discord server
win virtual Badges and climb the ranks
by participating unlock the secret
Patron Channel by winning and get your
art shown in the next pwnisher video so
what are you guys waiting for click that
link and let's get creating but hey for
real though huge shout outs to you sodon
for joining us today and walking us
through this super cool unique effect of
course yeah no worries thanks for having
me I I really enjoyed it and thanks for
having you know my video here absolutely
man yeah my pleasure do you have a place
where people can check out more of your
art though you can find me on Instagram
at @ sodam monore so we're like vampires
forever now right yeah for all
eternity and isn't sunlight like super
bad for us
then ouch ouch
[Music]
ouch
n